all right shall we start glad to see
that some people came back after
Wednesday um the topic of today will be
um generative AI models for denovo
protein design but first I will quickly
recap some of the most important concept
that you will need to understand like
the models I will explain today um and
then I will explain RF diffusion um a
diffusion model for backbone design and
after that I will also EXP protein and
pnn um also a generative model for
sequence design and in the end I will
give a little short demo demonstration
of of of the power of these
models so last Wednesday we have learned
that like proteins are chains of amino
acids and they fold into these complex
um 3D shapes based on the amino acid
interactions and the backbone of such a
pro prot consists of these linked
triangles of n c Alpha and C atoms so
this um would look like this for example
a backbone like a protein without side
chains so just the amino acid backbones
linked together and the difference
between um the 20 amino acids is
basically just um their side chains like
what is attached um to this C Alpha atom
but this n c Alpha and C triangle this
is common like to all um amino
acids and then we have also seen um
folding models like Alpha fold 2 which
predict protein structures from amino
acid
sequences and we have seen that Alpha
fold taking an input sequence first does
like a genetic database search uh to
look for similar sequences and makes in
a multisequence multiple sequence
alignment and then it also does like a
structure database
search um to generate the first
structure
prediction um from similar proteins that
of which a structure already
exists and then um with these three
inputs um it generates using this
sophisticated model architecture trained
on protein structures generates um a
finally refined structure prediction
then we have also looked at graph neural
networks and graphs which are ideally
suited to model on order data such as
proteins or protein
backbones
and in a graph like this a graph neural
network um Can Transform the data that
is stored in node and the data that is
stored in edges um through um message
passing through graph convolutions and
the resulting embeddings in notes and
edges will then um include information
about the connectivity and the
neighborhood of the of the nodes or the
edges and as last week was mostly about
protein engineering um this refers to
like to explore the protein Space by
modifying the sequence of an existing
natural protein to optim its properties
so the resulting proteins of when you
engineer a protein usually share most of
the sequence with the protein that
serves as a starting
point and they also are structurally
similar to to the Natural proteins you
used as input and now today we want to
talk about the noo protein design which
refers to designing a novel sequence
from scratch so this does not rely on
natural protein sequences but uses
computational methods to design
sequences that might potentially be very
different from all existing proteins so
there's this famous statement that um
Evolution has basically only explore the
tiny subset of all possible proteins
that could exist so if you look at the
whole um space of possible combinations
of amino acids then only a small part of
this already exists and there a lot of
space left to generate new
proteins um that haven't been like seen
or characterized
before
so now I will start by um explaining RF
diffusion U diffusion model for backbone
design and for this I will quickly
repeat what we have learned in one of
the previous lectures about like
principles behind diffusion models so
these models have been shown to achieve
St of the art performance in image
generation and you basically start with
images and over a number of time steps
you add increasing amounts of noise and
that at
intermediate um time steps you have
these noisy images that still clearly
resemble your uh input image but
eventually you will reach um a Time step
where um the image shows no resemblance
to your input image anymore so you
basically erased all the information in
the
image
and if you you then basically train a
neural network to undo one step of noise
and if you can successfully train these
networks um you can then sample from
your known gosan distribution and feed
this Pure Noise um into your models
which then do this repeated um steps of
D noising and eventually return like a
distribution that closely resembles the
one you trained on so they in this case
they will return a realistic image to
you and the same Concepts can be applied
through protein
structures
so you take a protein
structure um as training data but you um
noise these structures that you take
from the protein data bank and then the
model is trained to recover the ground
truth prediction the ground truth
structures from the noise
inputs and if you do this successfully
and train these models um then you can
generate new structures through this
iterative D noising from random
noise and to understand this RF
diffusion model we have to talk about
how you can add no to protein
structures and there's this Frame based
modeling of protein backbones that Alpha
fold and also RF diffusion use where um
you look at a
backbone as just triangles of n c Alpha
and C atoms so these three atoms that
are the backbone of every amino acid
they form a nearly planer rigid triangle
basically and each triangle in such a
structure can then be described by a
single translation and a single rotation
so a protein backbone um is then
basically just a set of L translations
and L rotations where L is the length of
the protein or the number of amino acids
in the protein and then because all
these triangles are described by a
translation and a rotation we add 3D um
we can add 3D gion noise to the
translation so basically perturb the the
C Alpha
coordinates and they also use um
Brownian motion on the manifold of
rotation
matrices so this noising strategy
basically transforms this set of
triangles from neatly aligned along a
protein backbone into randomly
distributed and
oriented and then they train a neural
network to reverse this process
so the training aim is to recover
original protein structures from the
noised version of these
structures and what you can see here is
one training step of RF diffusion so you
always take like at each time step you
take XT which is the current coordinates
which are initially random noise and
then um RF diffusion always directly
makes a prediction for the ground truth
structure of so it goes from XT to
x0 but then the next coordinate input to
the next um time step of the model will
not be this ground truth prediction but
it will be an
interpolation between XT and x0 so it
takes the currently the current
coordinates and makes step in the
direction of its ground truth
prediction and then this um
interpolation is then passed to the next
time step of the model and this ground
truth prediction is not discarded but
it's also passed to the next time step
so this is um what they call self-
conditioning the model can um use the
positions of the coordinates at the
current time step but also the predicted
ground truth coordinates of the previous
time step and this um strategy marketly
improved this RF diffusion
performance and another interesting
aspect of this model is that
um it is based on a protein structure
prediction model so on a folding model
which is called Rosetta fold and it's
quite similar to Alpha fold and it's
also accurate L predicts protein
structures from input
sequences like the thinking behind is
that we can um achieve improved
diffusion models for protein design by
taking advantage of like the deep
understanding of protein structures that
are that is contained in these protein
structure prediction models so we use
just um the weights of such a prediction
model as like a training starting point
so RF Fusion was developed through
fine-tuning of the Rosetta fold
structure prediction
Network and this Rosetta fold um looks
quite similar to like looking at the
inputs it is quite similar than Alpha
fold so it takes in the input sequence
that should be
folded and then it also searches for
homology proteins in a database so for
template structures and creates the
first
prediction based on these homologous
proteins first prediction of the protein
structures in form of like a par pawise
residue distance Matrix and also it
makes a first frame based representation
that's this representation of the
backbone consisting of all these
triangles that can be described with a
translation and a
rotation and then it outputs a predicted
structure for this sequence
and RF diffusion reuses this
architecture with almost no
changes um except the sequence input to
the folding model is now masked because
we don't have an input sequence anymore
and instead of the first prediction of
this Frame based representation of the
backbone we now have these diffused
coordinates so the noised coordinates
and then instead of this pair wise um
distance Matrix We have basically what
comes from this self- conditioning so we
have the prediction of the ground truth
coordinates x0 of the previous time step
so this was a Structure prediction model
but now it is fine-tuned using the same
architecture to predict also a protein
structure but with noise coordinates as
input and
this RF diffusion model can um is a
generative model for protein backbones
and it starting from random noise it can
really generate protein backbones that
are highly diverse you can see some
examples here on the right side and many
of the unconstrained designs show um
little similarity to structures seen
during training indicating that this
model can really gener generalize Beyond
its training
data and experimental characterization
also showed that most of these proteins
are really stable and soluble
yes at the moment what I explain now is
just unconstrained designs but I will um
come to the point of like condition
designs in a
minute
so RF diffusion can be like conditioned
for specific designs so it can kind of
be customized to specific design
challenges by the addition of external
potentials and by fine-tuning the model
so it's kind of like a
guiding guiding of the trajectory at
each step of this iterative D noising
process toward a specific design
objective and as an example um RF
diffusion was like conditioned with the
structure of a Tim Barrel protein so A
protein that has like this overall
structure and then RF diffusion was able
because it was conditioned with this
input structure to produce like diverse
designs with like roughly the same
overall
topology and another
interesting um experiment that they did
in this paper is um they built scaffolds
or backbones to hold a desired
Motif
so I have to explain this quickly so
p-53 protein is a protein that
suppresses um cancer growth so it's in
in in a cancer cell this protein
supposed to like recognize when a cell
becomes cancerous and initiate cell
death so it should prevent tumors from
growing and if tumors grow anyway they
have some kind of mechanisms to evade
this cell death right and one of these
aspects one of these mechanisms is this
mdm2 protein so this is really often
overexpressed in tumors and this mdm2
binds to p-53 and prevents p-53 from
initiating cell death so the cancer
cells can survive because they
overexpress this mdm2 which keeps p-53
from exerting its
function and the design task that they
tackled was to design a competitor
protein um that binds to mdm2 so that
mdm2 cannot bind to p53 anymore
so what they did is they took this mdm2
binding Helix from
p53 into their new designs so you can
see here this is the mdm2 protein that
usually binds to
p53 like it binds to this Helix of P 533
so they take this
Helix and they use RF diffusion fine
tuned on
complexes and condition it to include
this
Helix so and then they generate designs
they were able to generate designs that
strongly binds to this mdm2 and this is
like potentially like a candidate for a
cancer drop
basically and
some of you might be wondering um
because this was all about backbone
design right so a backbone doesn't have
amino acids yet we just designed a
structure of a
backbone with RF diffusion but this
backbone does not include any specific
amino acid sequence yet so to complete
the protein design we need to identify
an amino acid sequence that will
actually fold into this backbone
structure so the process is
um depicted here so far we have designed
a backbone and now we also need to kind
of equip this backbone with side chains
so we need to add an amino acid identity
to each of these backbone triangles and
what you can do is you design a backbone
then you run a model that designs a
sequence for this backbone and then you
can validate with Alpha fold so you take
the sequence that has been designed for
this backbone um give it to Alpha fold
which generates a structure for it and
then you can see if this structure
derived from the sequence um actually
has this backbone
design and a model that can solve this
task of the sequence design for a
specific backbone is this protein mpnn
model so it's also a generative model
but it's for sequence design
and um it follows this sequence from
structure objective so it takes a fixed
backbone and Designs a sequence that
will fold into this
backbone and it also uses like a
graph-based
representation of the backbone structure
um within its
architecture so this is kind of referred
to as the inverse folding problem right
so if you have a backbone like this here
in the C but you could model the
backbone like this this is only the
connected triangles of each amino acid
like the backbone triangles and now we
want to find a sequence that will fold
into the given structure so we kind of
equip this backbone with some side
chains that make sure that if this amino
acid chain is synthesized that guided
through these side chain interactions um
the protein will fold in this backbone
structure and for this this protein mpnn
model models this backbone structure
that you can see here on the right side
um as a graph and in this graph nodes
represent amino acid in this fixed
structure but more more specifically um
the alha atoms of the unknown amino
acids because it's only a backbone it
has no amino acid identities yet so um
the nodes are positions of calpha atoms
and then they just connect all nodes to
its 32 nearest neighbors so basically
each amino acid is connected to its 32
neighboring amino acid and by amino acid
here I mean um backbone positions of
amino acids
and then
the
sorry then these notes are the notes of
the graph and the edges of the graph
have to be featued so we put some input
data into these notes and for the notes
these are just just zeros so the node
features are initialized as zeros and
the edge features remember that each
Edge connects basically two amino acids
or C Alpha
atoms each Edge um is featued with a
couple of distances and these distances
refer to like all the distances that you
can like compute between two triangles
of these amino acids so if you have
these um two amino acid triangles The
Edge features connecting these will
contain like all these
distances and this encodes somehow like
this spatial orientation of these amino
acids and then the first part of the
model is this U message passing neural
network network the graph convolution
where these initial note features which
which are zeros and the initial Edge
features which are these distances are
transformed with graph convolutions so
you can this is my like an example
structure with these distances in in the
edge features and these zeros in in the
node features and through um message
passing on this structure the
information about um spatial environment
of a node is encoded in its node
features and same also counts for edes
and the same you can basically see here
so what is in this red frame here is the
message passing neural network part of
the
model so you can see we take these
distances The Edge features and the note
features and then we do this message
passing so we update the notes with an
information flow from the edges to the
notes and then we update the edges again
we update the notes again and this
circle is repeated three times so the
graph this graph convolution generates
New Edge and node embeddings which
encode information about like the
spatial neighborhood of an amino
acid and then in the second part of the
model this is basically the decoder this
does some kind of Auto regressive
decomposition so it is
um like going through the protein
sequence um which is still unknown and
predicts like one amino acid at a time
so it is run as many times as there are
amino acids so it always takes Edge
features and the node
features and from these embeddings that
are um saved in the
respective um notes of the graph for
each amino acid um the model predicts
like a categorical probability
distribution for for the 20 amino acids
from which the next amino acid in the
sequence is
sampled and this takes in the edge
features the note features from the
graph and also the sequence that has
been predicted already so it always
predicts one
sequence uh using the edge and the note
features and then goes on to the to the
next amino acid and always takes into
account the part of the sequence it has
already
predicted and
yesu times doesn't mean that each amet
is aware of the spatial information of
the there at distance
less and if that's the case isn't that
limitation because we want every amino
acid to be aware of every other amino
acid
in
the um I think when we were looking
at we said that doing gration we to in
from the other neighbors so
doing gration would me to let
information flow from two neighbors and
three neighbors if you do the gration
two times and so on and so forth and I'm
wondering if this doing just three times
it's liming because we wouldn't have
flow of information from
four or
five position down the
line yes and that's a good point
um so the question is whether um more
like more rounds of convolution would be
better because information would be
flowing from Border in the graph like
not only three steps away and I think um
three times basically already encoded
kind of the spatial neighborhood of of
this amino acid well enough also
considering that each amino acid is
connected directly to its 32 nearest
neighbors so um I'm not entirely sure
but um I guess this they have like
tested this and it it's probably enough
to do this three times
um yeah but it's really important that
also the edge features are changed so
it's not only note features that are
updated based on other notes and other
edges it's also the edge features that
are updated based on other edges and
other
nodes good um the training data for this
model as I said is like proteins with
known sequence and experimentally solved
structures and then these from these
solved structures um the amino acid side
chains are removed to have only the back
bone remaining and then these side
chains should be or the amino acid
identities should be rediscovered by
protein
mpnn and the loss um for the training is
basically a categorical cross entropy
for for all the amino aciids so you just
compare um the true um probability
distribution um to the probability
distribution that the model outputs for
a specific amino acid position
and the training performance of this
model is about
50% and this refers to sequence recovery
so you take a protein with a specific
sequence remove the side chains so you
basically take away the sequence
information
and then the model tries to recover this
sequence but it only has 50% recovery
rate basically and you might think that
this is really low but we have to keep
in mind that for many positions in a
protein structure several amino acids
might be like a possible solution like
several amino acids might be might fit
at a certain location so the important
thing to do is this structure validation
so the sequences that the protein mpnn
generates we
can um take them and check if they fold
into the right structure because that's
actual Target right um so then it this
this workflow is dep depicted here you
you have an input structure you extra
extract the backbone remove all side
chains and then you use protein MN to
ReDiscover these amino acid identities
basically what side chains are attached
where and then given this sequence you
um hand it to Alpha 2 which predicts
predicts a structure for the sequence
and then you will um
you will see if the predicted structure
by Alpha fold um closely matches the
input
structure
and for this I have like a short
demo so this is basically the same
figure that you've um seen just now and
this is a demonstration of protein mnn
so we can take an input structure and we
will take here this
one ycr which is actually the mdm2
protein of this um cancer example I
showed you before and then you have some
settings here so you can say we we want
to redesign chain a
and let's say we want to generate four
new sequences for this
backbone you will also have like a
sampling temperature so if you make this
higher than the the sequence Discovery
will be kind of more creative and you
will have more diverse
sequences and then we can um run
this and this will be quite fast because
the model is really fast has only 1.7
million parameters and then you will see
here this is our original sequence of
this mdm2 protein and these are the four
sequences
um that M protein mpnn has generated for
this backbone so these should fold into
the same
structure and you can see here the
recovery rate is 44 to 47 more or less
so these sequences have
only less than 50% identity with the
input um protein this
mdm2
and to see if these sequences
actually take on this backbone structure
that we desire the same as this mdm2
protein we can now run Alpha fold on all
these um sequences that have been
generated but uh this will take a while
even though I chose um a small protein
so I will um continue with the
presentation in the meantime
so this protein MPN solves this sequence
design problem so finding sequences that
fold into specific backbone
structures and in Silicon experimental
validation show that it can do this with
high accuracy and this graph-based
modeling of the 3D backbone um and this
message passing neural network derived
note features are crucial for this model
model's
performance and also very interesting is
that also here you can
um include desired
motifs
um by just keeping a part of the
sequence
fixed
so you just let a protein MPN only
design the sequence around a parts that
you want to keep fixed so if we go back
to the example of this 53
mbm2 um
interaction we have seen that um using
this
Helix and Ro um RF diffusion we have
generated this backbone structure that
holds this Helix and then binds to mdm2
as we desired and now that we have this
backbone we have to give it some amino
acids because it's just the backbone so
far so we can use protein mpnn but for
example we want this still to bind to
mdm2 right so it might be a good idea to
keep the amino acids that are part of
this Helix in p53 to make sure it still
binds to mdm2 so we can use protein
MN but um give it as input also
that like a certain set of amino should
be located here and then it will just
design the sequence the remaining
sequence around this fixed
part so let's go back this has finished
now and you can see
here that we have the four
sequences and the root mean Square
deviation we can sort for this then you
can see that sequence zero is the best
one and the model is very confident
about this prediction and the recovery
is uh 44% so this sequence has only 44%
sequence identity with
mdm2 and here you can see the
structure so in Gray you can see the
input structure so the template we used
the mdm2
protein and in blue you can see um the
structure of our newly designed
sequences so even though these sequences
are very different somehow only 4 44%
sequence
identity um protein MPN has correctly um
suggested these sequences because they
um really fold into this backbone
structure
so to summarize RF diffusion is like a
generative model for protein backbones
that generates highly diverse protein
backbones from random noise and then
protein mpnn is a generative model for
sequence design that binds sequences
that fold into these specific
structures and this combination of RF
diffusion and protein MPN is just like
one potential approach to boval protein
design uh it's a powerful approach but
this this lecture has like in no way
been um like an exhaustive overview over
this field this field is super Dynamic
you can hardly keep up with all the
papers that are released in protein
design but these two models um they are
um super interesting because they are um
they work really well and they are
publicly available for everyone to use
and um you can also include desired mode
motives or
topologies which allows you to design
proteins for a specific application
which makes them a lot more interesting
I
think good um I'm at the end of the
presentation if if you have any
questions I'd be happy to try and answer
them
about representation of structure
sometimes
trans um at least Alpha fold uses this
kind of representation and also um
Rosetta fold as well and also um or if
diffusion does the same
but yeah there there would be other kind
of representations I think um
yeah but it's it's hard to say I'm not
not nothing comes to my mind right
now um if they do these unconstrained
designs then um I mean this is not
specifically encoded in these
representations really just these
rotations and translations but what they
can do of course is they can condition
RFD Fusion to form a helix or a beta
sheet at a certain location by just
adding some external potentials that in
each diff Den noising time step just
pushes pushes the cordinates a little
bit in in the correct direction that's
the one they the direction they want and
then they can end up with designs that
have some desired topologies
another question yeah demo that show so
all these four sequences have the same
backg structure as
the um yes I mean we
can this is the picture yeah this is the
sequence zero right this is the sequence
zero yes so we can check maybe sequence
three has the highest
rmsd um of these four sequences that we
generated so maybe we can um show this
one and then I guess you will be able to
see some more deviations from
the it's not really the case um it's
still quite similar to the input
structure mdm2 very actually different
sequences can have the
same
yes I mean we could maybe increase the
um the temperature of the model and then
um generate more sequences and then we
will probably also get sequences that
are not so precise and have quite a
different backbone um but the best
predictions
um as far as I've tried it always looks
quite quite like the input structure
okay then
uh thank you for your attention and uh
if there are any more questions we can
happy to answer them
after afterwards